Ambiguity,
paradox,
confusion are,
uh,
also some of my favorite subjects.
Um,
uh,
the two lions that we often see in the
Far East,
uh,
it's,
they're supposed to represent confusion
and paradox and they guard the gate to
heaven.
So if you want to get to heaven quote,
you have to be comfortable with
confusion and with paradox and one
example of being comfortable with
paradox as a,
we often hear that we should accept life
the way it is and uh,
but of course there are many things that
we don't accept a,
so we can have the paradox of accepting
that we can't accept.
I mean,
we can't accept violence against women
or children or even against other men,
but we can accept that we can't accept
that.
So,
uh,
the paradox in this case,
it's extremely important.
Uh,
so it's not a whitewash to say,
hey,
I accept everything.
Uh,
that's nonsense to begin with.
but where do you parts of,
where do you say that you accept
something,
something or not?
And being comfortable with the paradox
of accepting,
but also accepting that we do not accept
certain things.
Uh,
that's,
that's how paradox plants plays itself
out and confusion,
is that we live in an extremely complex
world and uh,
it's not a straight and narrow.
Most things have an upside and a
downside and to weigh them out is,
it's very difficult,
you know,
we,
we would love to have a very simple
answer and white answer is a good for me
as a bad for me,
but,
uh,
that's very rarely the case.
We evolved to want to have simple
answers because the brain then doesn't
have to work overtime to analyze any
situation and the more complex the
situation and the more confusing,
the more the brain has to work.
That's why we don't like confusion.
We want to have simple,
straightforward,
black and white answers,
but that's probably not going to happen
for anything.
I personally don't like the word right
and wrong,
uh,
because for different people,
right and wrong looks very different.
I think that it can be coached and a
little bit of a different way.
So I like to look at things that work or
that don't work.
I believe that human beings
fundamentally want life to flourish.
We love and when we see life flourish,
be it a new flower or a tree sprouting
in the spring time or any beautiful new
thing that we experience a new baby,
it's,
it's just we'd love it and we have a
really positive feeling towards when
life flourishes,
a so right and wrong,
gets it very much into a mental status.
And we compare to a whole list of what
we think is good for live on,
what we think is bad for life.
Uh,
but underlying,
I think it's much more interesting to
pay attention to whether something works
to have life flourish or not.
So if you step on an ant,
obviously that doesn't help very much
for life to flourish.
Is it right or wrong to kill a mosquito?
I don't know.
You know,
I mean,
in my book,
that's works for me.
So the mosquito doesn't give me malaria,
so it helps my life to flourish.
But obviously it doesn't help them.
Mosquitoes life to flourish.
So,
uh,
I,
I believe it's much more valuable to
recognize it in terms of working and not
working rather than right and wrong.